before we get into the meat of algebra i
wanted to give you a quote from one of
the greatest minds in human history
galileo galilei because i think this
quote encapsulates the true point of
algebra and really mathematics in
general he said philosophy is written in
that great book whichever lies before
our eyes i mean the universe but we
cannot understand it if we do not first
learn the language and grasp the symbols
in which it is written
this book is written in the mathematical
language without which one wanders in
vain through a dark labyrinth so very
dramatic but very deep and this really
is the point of of mathematics and what
we'll see as we start getting deeper
into and deeper into algebra is that
we're going to start abstracting things
and we're going to start getting to core
ideas that start explaining really how
the universe is structured sure these
ideas can be applied to things like
economics and finance and physics and
chemistry but at their core they're the
same idea and so they're even more
fundamental more pure than any one of
those applications and to see what i
mean by getting down to the root idea
let's go with a i guess we could we you
know we started with the very grand you
know the philosophy of the universe is
written in mathematics but let's start
with a very concrete simple idea but
we'll keep abstracting and we'll see how
the same idea connects across many
domains in our universe so let's just
say we're at a store and we're going to
buy something and there's a sale the
sale says that it is 30 off
30 off and i'm interested i don't shop
at my two fancy stores so let's say i'm
interested in a pair of pants and the
pair of pants before the sale even is is
about 20 bucks and that is about how
much i spend on my pants
so i'm interested in a 20 pair of pants
but it's even better there's a 30
percent there's a 30 off sale on these
pants well how would i think about how
much i'm going to get off of that 20
and this isn't algebra yet this is
something that you've probably had
exposure to you would multiply the 30
percent times the 20
so you would say your discount
your discount
is equal to you could write it as thirty
percent
times twenty dollars i'll do the twenty
dollars in
in purple or you could write it if you
wanted to write this as a decimal you
could write this as zero point zero
times 20 dollars and if you were to do
the math you would get six dollars so
nothing nothing new over there
but what if i want to generalize a
little bit that's the discount on this
particular pierre pair of pants but what
if i wanted to know the discount on
anything in the store well then i could
say well let let x
let x be the price let me just in a
different color so i'm just going to
make a symbol let x be
the price of the the product i want to
buy price the non-discount price
non-discount
non-discount price of the product of the
product in the store
so now all of a sudden we can say that
our discount we can say our discount
is equal to thirty percent
thirty percent times x
thirty percent times x or if we wanted
to write it as a decimal we could write
if we were to write 30 as a decimal we
could write 0.30
times x
times
x now this is interesting now you give
me the price of any product in the store
and i can substitute it in for x and
then i can essentially multiply 0.3
times that and i would get the discount
so now we're starting to very slowly
we're starting to get into the the
abstraction of algebra and we'll see
that these will get much more nuanced
and deep and frankly more beautiful as
we start studying more and more kind of
algebraic algebraic ideas
but we aren't done here we can abstract
this even more over here we've said
we've generalized this for any product
we're not just saying for this twenty
dollar product if there's a ten dollar
product we can put that ten dollar
product in here for x and then we would
say three point three zero times ten and
the discount would be would be three
dollars it might be a hundred dollar
project then the discount would be
thirty
but let's generalize even more let's say
well what is the discount for any given
sale when the sale is a certain
percentage so now we can say that the
discount
let me define a variable so let
let's let let's let m equal or i'll say
p just so it makes sense let's p is
equal to
is equal to the percentage off
percentage
percentage off
now what can we do well now we can say
that the discount
the discount
is equal to the percentage off in these
other examples we were picking 30
percent but we can say now it's p it's
the percentage off
it's p
that's the percentage off
times the product in question times the
price the non-discount price of the
product in question well that was x the
discount is equal to p
times x now this is really interesting
now we have a general way of calculating
a discount for any given percentage off
and any given product x
and we didn't have to use these words in
these letters we could have said let y
equal the discount
let
y is equal to the discount
then we could have written the same
underlying idea instead of writing
discount we could have written y
is equal to the percentage off
isn't equal to the percentage off p
times the non-discount price of the
product
times x and you could have defined these
letters any way you wanted instead of
writing y there you could have written a
greek letter or you could have written
any symbol there as long as you can keep
track of that that symbol represents the
actual dollar discount but now things
get really interesting because we can
use this type of an exp of a
relationship which is an equation you're
equating y to this right over here
that's why we call it an equation this
can be used for things that are
completely unrelated to the price the
discount price at at the store over here
you might have so in physics you'll see
that force
is equal to mass times acceleration the
letters are different but these are
fundamentally the same idea we could
have let y is equal to force we could
let y is equal to force
and m
is equal to
or mass is equal to p so let me write p
is equal to mass and this wouldn't be a
an intuitive way to define it but i want
to show you that this is the same idea
the same relationship but it's being
applied to two completely different
things and we could say x is equal to
acceleration
we could say x
we could say x is equal to
acceleration
well then the famous force is equal to
mass times acceleration can be rewritten
and it's really the same exact idea as y
which we've defined as force can be
equal to mass which we're going to use
the symbol p which is equal to p
times acceleration we're just going to
happen to use the letter x here times x
well this is the exact same equation
this is the exact same equation we can
see that we can take this equation and
it can apply to things in economics
economics or it can apply to things in
finance
or it can apply to things in computer
science or logic or electrical
engineering or anything accounting
there's an infinite number of
applications of this one equation and
what's neat about mathematics and what's
neat about algebra in particular is
we can focus on this abstraction
we can focus on the abstract here and we
can manipulate the abstract here and
what we discover from these ideas from
these manipulations can then go and be
reapplied to all of all of these other
applications to all of them and even
neater is kind of telling us
the true structure of the universe if
you were to strip away all of these
human definitions and all these human
applications so for example we could say
look if y is equal to p times x so
literally if someone said hey this is y
and it says and someone says on the
other hand they say i have p times x i
could say well you have the same thing
in both of your hands and if you were to
divide one of them by a number and you
if you wanted them to still be equal you
would divide the other one by that
number so for example for example let's
say
we know that y is equal to p times x
what if you wanted to have them both be
equal and you say well what is y divided
by x is going to be equal to well y was
equal to p times x so y divided by x is
going to be the same thing as p times x
divided by x but now this is interesting
because p times x divided by x well if
you multiply by something and then
divide by that something it's just to
say you're going to get your original
number if you if you multiply by 5 and
divide by 5 you're just going to start
with p or whatever this number is so
those would cancel out but we were able
to manipulate the abstraction here and
get
y
over x is equal to p let me make that x
green
y over x is equal to p
and now this has implications this has
implications for every one of these
ideas one is telling us a fundamental
truth about the universe almost devoid
of any of these applications but now we
can go and take them back to any place
that we applied and what they're really
interesting thing is we're going to find
you they're an infinite number of
applications and we're going to and we
don't even know frankly most of them
we're going to discover new ones for
them in a thousand years and so
hopefully this gives you a sense for why
galileo said what he said about really
mathematics is is really the language
with we can understand the philosophy of
the universe and that's why people tell
us that if a completely alien life form
would ever contact humans it probably
mathematics would probably be our first
common ground the place that we can
start to to
form a basis that we can start to
communicate from